Ich bin der SUCH TENDIGARS AutoSale Station.
Ich füre hier gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch.
Ich frage Ihnen, wie Sie sich das ein paar Mal über die Frage stellen.
Sie haben mich über die Frage über die Frage über die Frage.
Sie haben mich damit einfach verstanden.
Natürlich, gerne.
Was heißt Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Berger.
Thomas Berger.
Herr Berger, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 4. November 1975.
1900?
1975.
75.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin circa 1 Meter 72 groß
und wiege ungefähr 71 Kilogramm.
Herr Berger, welche Bescheide haben Sie?
Was wird Sie so heute?
Ich bin heute hier, weil ich seit ungefähr 5 Tagen sehr stark zu Husten muss
und Fieber habe, was einfach nicht besser wird.
Seit 5 Tagen starker Husten mit Fieber?
Ja.
Haben Sie Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Ich habe meine Temperatur gestern gemessen.
Die war hoch, die war bei circa 38,9.
38,9.
Gestern, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Husten mit Auswurf oder trockenen Husten?
Ne, da kommt Auswurf.
Mit Auswurf.
Welche Verbarbe war es?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Braun.
Können Sie bitte Ihr Auswurf beschreiben?
Ganz genau beschreiben.
Schleimig oder wie ist das?
Genau, schleimig.
Herr Berger, wie hat Ihr Husten oder wie haben Ihre Beschwerden angefangen?
Plöstlich oder langsam?
Ja, es war nicht plötzlich, es war so schleichend.
Es war zuerst ein bisschen trockener Husten
und dann wurde es schleimig im Husten.
Okay, ist zunächst trockener Husten?
Danach mit Auswurf.
Haben Sie immer Husten oder wie ist das?
Ich muss stark Husten, ja.
In der Nacht, tagsüber?
Auch, egal.
Immer.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden verstärken oder verliehen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich tief einatme,
dann habe ich stärkeren Husten und einen stärkeren Husten reiz.
Ich muss auch etwas einenatmen.
Haben Sie begleiten der andere Symptome
wie Turak Schmerzen oder Burus Schmerzen
oder andere Körperteile Schmerzen?
Wenn ich Huste, dann tut das weh!
Es ist schon so stark, dass ich kaum Husten kann.
Während Husten haben Sie Schmerzen, richtig?
Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Eigentlich überall muss man sagen.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Eigentlich überall.
Überall? Okay.
Alle Brustbereiche.
Genau.
Haben Sie
Mjagí Musiker Schmerzen?
Oder Haltschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, wenn ich husste, dann habe ich schon Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, wenn ich dann husste, dann auch Kopfschmerzen.
Ja.
Ja, streiten Ihre Brustschmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Am Rippenbereich.
Im Rippen würde ich sagen.
Rippen, okay.
Haben Sie Blut in Ihrem Ausruf bemerkt?
Nein.
Ja, Ihre Beschwerden langsam,
hat langsam begonnen.
Ja, wissen Sie, gibt es einen Auslöser?
Zum Beispiel in Ihrer Umgebung gibt es jemanden,
der ähnliche Beschwerde hat?
Nein.
Vor Ihnen? Nein.
Haben Sie bei diesem Zeitraum seit fünf Tagen
Ihren Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin besucht?
Ich war bei meinem Hausarzt gewesen, ja.
Vor zwei Tagen.
Vor zwei Tagen? Genau.
Er hat gesagt, dass alles so weit okay ist
und ich abwarten müsste.
Ich viel trinken soll.
Okay, haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen
oder wurde ein Medikament verschrieben?
Nein, er hat mir einen Schleimlöser aufgeschrieben.
Wie heißt es?
ACC.
ACC hat auch so eine Bausetablette,
aber die hilft nicht wirklich.
Gegen Ihre Fieber haben Sie etwas eingenommen?
Paracetamol, ja.
Paracetamol.
Wie viel, welche Dosierung qual ist es?
500 mg.
Ungefähr 3-4 mal am Tag.
Können Sie wiederholen, bitte?
3-4 mal am Tag.
3-4, okay. Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Also das Fieber wird dadurch weniger, ja.
Aber es steigt immer wieder.
Herr Belger, haben Sie auch Steilfrost nach Katzschweiß?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Nein, auch kein Katzschweiß, aber ich schwütze viel.
Ja, haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ja, doch. Also mein Herz steht schneller.
Okay, wer dann, die Fieber oder immer, haben Sie es bemerkt?
Die ganze Zeit eigentlich. Die ganze Zeit.
Okay, ja.
Haben Sie gemessen Ihr Herzfrequenz?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen über oder schwindelig?
Schwindelig manchmal, aber nicht über.
Nicht über.
Ja, schwindelig, ja, dieser Schwindeligkeit ist auch seit 5 Tagen oder?
Seit 3-4 Tagen ungefähr.
Okay, beide sind im Zeitraum.
Ja, haben Sie zusätzlich das Atemnot?
Wenn ich schwutze, aber ansonsten nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Sturrgang?
Nein.
Haben Sie in dieser Zeit Ab- oder Sugenomen?
Ich denke, dass ich in den letzten 5 Tagen abgenommen habe, weil ich wenig esse.
Ja, beide sind im Zeitraum.
Ich glaube, sie sind keine Appetitlosigkeit.
Sie haben Appetitlosigkeit.
Ich esse weniger, weil ich mich nicht gut fühle.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf? Können Sie gut schlafen?
Nein, ich muss sehr stark holen.
Ja, müssen Sie, ja, oder wie viele Kisse benutzen Sie in der Nacht?
Eins.
Müssen Sie eins?
Ja, Herr Berger.
Leiden Sie an chronisch Erkrankungen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sehr gut. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde am Knie operiert.
Knie operiert?
10, 15 Jahre ungefähr.
Vor 10 Jahren?
10 oder 15 Jahre ungefähr.
Gab es eine Komplikation nach der Operation?
War alles in Ordnung?
Nein, wir haben eine Miniskussoperation.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie außer Palästamol und ACS
irgendein Medikament Regalmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein.
Haben Sie allerlei Gehäute und Fertilikaten herbergen?
Rauchense?
Ja.
Und wie viel Zigaretta rauchen Sie täglich?
Ich rauche jetzt weniger, in den letzten 5 Tagen, aber ich rauche seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren?
Ja.
Und wie viel Zigaretta, wo manerweise rauchen Sie?
Ja, so 15, 20 ungefähr am Tag.
Herr Berger, nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Selten.
Was trinken Sie und was meinen Sie mit Selten?
Einmal im Monat oder alle zwei Monat, nicht viel.
Was trinken Sie?
Kompromiss, wenn ich in Gesellschaft bin, Cocktails oder Bier.
Okay, Cocktails oder Bier.
Herr Berger, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Wie treiben Sie Sport, Herr Berger?
Ich versuche, ich gehe viel spazieren, ich fahre viel Fahrrad, aber so aktiv Sport.
Aber ich versuche, mich viel zu bewegen.
Ich muss auf der Arbeit immer viel laufen.
Laufen?
Ja Herr Berger, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronische oder wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, meine Eltern haben beide Blutwuchtruck.
Mein Vater hat Diabetes.
Typ 1 oder Typ 2, wissen Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich glaube schon, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, haben Sie Impfliste dabei?
Nein.
Gegen Influencer, sind Sie geimpft?
Nein, auch nicht.
Sie sind jung, aber Sie müssen nicht.
Aber wenn Sie diese Impfungen...
Mein Vater hat nichts gesagt.
Er hat nicht gesagt, dass ich Impfungen lassen soll beim letzten Checkup.
Sie müssen nicht, aber wenn Sie häufig krank sind,
könnte es sein.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewiesen?
Ich war in den USA.
Wann waren Sie dort?
Jetzt vor ungefähr 4 Wochen.
Wie lange sind Sie dort geliebt?
Eine Woche.
Vor 4 und 5 Wochen?
Haben Sie gesagt, richtig?
Ja.
Herr Berger, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lagerarbeiter.
Lagerarbeiter?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Mit wem leben Sie allein?
Allein.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Normaler Stress.
Normaler Stress, okay.
Herr Berger,
wir sind am Ende des Gesprächs.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Können Sie mir helfen?
Ja, ich werde Sie gleich körperlich untersuchen
und danach anscheinend Blut abnehmen
und wegen Hustern ein Grundgernbild,
eine Grundgernbild durchführen.
Und danach, nachdem ich alle Ergebnisse habe,
werde ich Sie sofort informieren.
Legen Sie sich bitte auf die Delike.
Ihr beiden, oder kann ich denn nach Hause?
Ja, bis Ergebnisse müssen Sie hier bleiben
und werde ich Sie sofort informieren.
Legen Sie sich bitte auf die Delike zur Untersuchung.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe.
Herr Berger, haben Sie früher ein Lieblings-Wäschwerden?
Nein, eigentlich so starken Husten habe ich lange nicht mehr gehabt.
Ich habe nicht mehr gehört.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Ich habe nicht so starken Husten habe ich lange nicht mehr gehabt.
OK. Wie stark Ihre Buserschmerzen auf einem Skala 0,10 und 0,10
keine Schmerzen, denn sehr stark Schmerzen?
4, 5.
Danke.
Noch eine Frage?
Ja.
Erschuldigung, ich habe nicht Clara gehört.
Sie haben in Ihrem Umfeld oder der Familien ähnliche Beschwerden jemandem getroffen?
Nein, nicht das Musken.
Und haben Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, vor drei Jahren.
Wie viel Mal?
Ich glaube dreimal. Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Okay. Und auch waren Sie beim Covid-19 krank?
Ja, positiv. Ich war mal positiv.
Okay, danke.
Guten Tag. Ihr habt eine Frage.
Und haben Sie Atemnut?
Wenn ich huste, habe ich manchmal Atemnut.
Wenn ich stark husten muss.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Tritt das Fieber im Schuben oder ständig auf?
Wenn ich Medikamente nehme, habe ich kein Fieber.
Aber wenn das Medikament wieder nachlässt, die Wirkung habe ich weiter in den Fieber.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie ein Brennen im Hals?
Nein.
Haben Sie einen Laufen der Nase oder ein Verschub der Nase?
Muskelschwea?
Muskelschmerz?
Nein, ich habe nicht Antworten.
Nein, ich habe auch keine Laufen der Nase.
Danke schön.
Ich habe keine Unterschenkel, Odeva.
Geh dir das Schmerz?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können wir als Satske anfangeln?
Ja, ich fange.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberast.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen, hätten Sie kurz Zeit.
Ja, klar.
Der Patient heißt Herr Thomas Berger.
Er ist 49 Jahre alt.
Er ist 71 kg schwer.
Der Patient stande sich heute bei uns seit fünf Tagen.
Er ist mit einem starken Traum.
Er war mit einem Schuput.
Am Anfang war er trocken.
Aber momentan war er mit einem Schuput.
Er war mit einem braunen Traum.
Er war mit einem schleimigen Traum.
Er ist mit einem egg, das 48,9°C hat.
Er war mit einem schweren Traum.
Er war mit einem schleimigen Traum.
Söder hat der Patient Dispino und Torekalgie ohne Astralung.
Seine Torekalgie und Dispino treten beim Tief-Einatmen auf.
Der Patient hat seinen Hausarzt bei diesem Zeitraum vor zwei Tagen besucht.
Der Patient hat bei diesem Zeitraum nur dieses Medikament ACC und Paristamol 500 mg 3-4 pro Tag eingenommen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwählig bis auf Tachycardi und beschwerde Bedingte in Appetanz, Insomnien und Vertigo.
Die Gewichtveränderung wurde verneint.
Der Patient hatte keine Vorerkrankungen.
Bei dem Patient wurde eine Menisküsoperation durchgeführt vor zehn oder fünf zehn Jahren.
Der Patient hat keine Medikamente.
Er hat keine Energie und keine Unvertierlichkeiten.
Der Patient braucht seit 20 Jahren 15 bis 20 Zigarette täglich.
Er trinkt selten Alkohol, einmal Promenat, Cocktail oder Biage.
Der Patient hat eine Drogenkonsum. Er fährt und geht spazieren.
Sein Vater leidet an Arterenhypertone und Diabismillitus.
Seine Mutter leidet auch an Arterenhypertone.
Er ist ein Serkant.
Der Impfstatus ist nicht bekannt.
Der Patient ist vor vier oder fünf Wochen in den USA gereist.
Der Patient ist dort gebelieben.
Der Patient arbeitet als Lagearbeiter.
Er ist geschieden, hat keine Kinder.
Er lebt allein.
Der Anamnest an den Angaben ist am ersten auf einer Nichtunflänzer.
Der Anamnest ist nicht so hoch.
Am ersten, was?
Der Anamnest an den Angaben ist am ersten auf Wehrkältung.
Der Anamnest ist sehr stark.
Welche Differen müsste auch Diagnosen sein?
Der Anamnest, der Impfstatus, ist sehr stark.
Ja, ich kann Pynomenus sagen, als Verdachtdiagnose.
Ja, Pynomenus sagen.
Ja, Browner Auswurf ist infrage.
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Covid-Influenza in Betracht.
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose.
Also, Pynomonie zu bestimmen und meine Differenzialdiagnose auszuschließen,
werde ich dann Patienten körperlich untersuchen und mit Vitalparameter nach der Runde.
Wie können Sie denn zwischen Pynomenie und den Fernseher die Diagnostik unterscheiden?
Ja, Influenza oder ich glaube insbesondere erwarte ich jemanden,
in seiner Umgebung eine Beswerde hat.
Ich meine nicht anerlässlich, diagnostisch.
Diagnostisch?
Ja.
Wie Sie haben gesagt, es könnten drei Sachen sein, es kann eine Influenza sein, es kann eine Prämonie sein,
es kann eine Prüveinfektion sein.
Wie können Sie das unterscheiden, trifft es ja diagnostisch?
Ja, bei Influenza erwarte ich höher Pergse, 38,9 ist nicht so hoch für Influenza.
Was können Sie an Diagnose machen?
Okay, außer Untersuchung werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Großes Blutbild, wie können Leckostos oder Lempostos anschauen.
Und ein Syndoxparameter wie CRP-BSG.
Und, was war es, Nase und Hals?
Abschüttrich.
Abschüttrich?
Routine, Laborwerte werde ich auch im Laborbeistimmeln nassen, wie Nirenwerte, Leberwerte.
PSH ist, ja, können wir auch bestimmen lassen.
Was kann man noch machen?
Was noch?
Freund Günther Rags, haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, Jean-Claire Bild, gegebenenfalls Computerisotomographie.
Was noch?
Sie können Sie damit Influenza und Covid theoretisch ausschließen,
können Sie diese Tests machen?
Sie sind in jedem Krankenhaus vorhanden.
Man kann Influenza-Schnelltest machen, Influenza-A, zum Beispiel.
Oder man kann auch sagen, wir machen den Covid-Test.
Die haben dabei sehr schnelle Tests, wo man das ausschließen kann,
ob eine virale Infektion in diesem Fall vorliegt.
Okay, ja.
Nasenabstrich kommt so vor, oder?
Ich glaube, die machen Nasenrachenabstriche.
Okay, sollte sich der Verdacht der Oknose bestätigen können,
werde ich den Patienten eigentlich seine Beschwerden nicht so schlimm.
Ja, er hat Husten mit Feber.
Was sagt der Produktivenauswurf?
Bei einer Viralinfektion hat man eher produktiven Auswurf
oder hat man eher trockenen Auswurf?
Bei Virusinfekt hat man meist trockenen Husten,
so reizhusten,
dass man immer sehr viel, sehr oft husten muss.
Bei dieser Patient beklagt er, dass er eine produktiven Husten hat,
bräuchig verfärbt.
Ja, okay.
Das bedeutet, wir können diesen Patienten stationär aufnehmen, oder?
Ja, man muss nicht den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Wenn man den Verdacht auf eine Neumbonie hat,
gibt es bestimmte Kriterien.
Ja, ob der Patient Dispinau hat,
ich habe vor zwei oder drei Tagen es gelesen.
Kurb oder?
Ja.
Kurb plus 65.
Bei der Patient, wenn der Patient ein Punkt positiv ist,
sollen wir ambulant behandeln.
Mit zwei Punkten müssen wir stationär aufnehmen.
Wie viele Punkte hat der Patient?
Wie viele Punkte.
Wir sollen Rundtest durchführen lassen.
Oder laut dieser Kriterie?
Was ist das für eine Stiftung?
CRB, wofür steht CRB?
Kurb 65, 65.
Kurb 65, wofür steht das?
Ja, Konfusion.
Erste Punkt ist Konfusion.
Hat der Konfusion?
Ja, nein.
Der Patient, der Beschwerde, das ist negativ.
Ist der 65 Jahre?
Nein, das ist auch negativ.
Wie ist der Atemfrequenz?
Der Patient, er wird bei der Untersuchung beurteilen.
Mit Rundtest oder?
Ja, Haarstoff.
Das wird nicht immer benutzt.
Wichtig ist der Blutdruck zum Beispiel.
Das bedeutet, wir sollen diesen Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Wie viele Patients?
Wir werden Antibiotikum begenen.
Was haben Sie gegeben?
Aber ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Was haben Sie gehofft?
Erster Laktan.
Penicillin ist immer gut.
Penicillin, Erster Laktan, Antibiotika.
Wir beginnen mit Penicillin.
Und auch er hat...
Also Aminopenicillin, ne?
Aminopenicillin.
Ich penicillin, Faul, sondern Aminopenicillin.
Ja, Amoxicillin.
Zum Beispiel, genau.
Plus, glaube, Lanza, zum Beispiel.
Aber auch.
Und auch, ja, symptomatische Behandlung werden wir, ja, weitermachen.
Und der Patient nimmt Parastomol und Assese.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, vielleicht ist das genug.
Und vielleicht können wir auch krank schreiben.
Zur Isolation.
Aber die Aussatz machen müssen Sie nicht.
Okay.
Und der muss auch arbeiten.
Ja, das ist alles von meiner Seite.
Aber Sie können ihm Medikamente mitgeben über das Wochenende.
Sie können ihm Medikamente aufschreiben, Rezept aufschreiben.
Ja.
Ja, Amoxicillin ist...
Ja, genau. Geben Sie mit oder schreiben eine Rezept auf
und sagen, er soll morgen zum Hausarzt gehen.
Okay.
Damit er weiter verschreiben kann.
Ja, dieser System ist anders.
Ja, als in Türkei.
Ja, wie lernen.
Ja.
Also, das Wichtigste ist hier zu unterscheiden,
ob wir eine Viralinfektion haben,
wo wir keine Antibiotikun brauchen,
oder ob wir eine Diabologe, eine Lungenentzündung haben.
Und wir können das diagnostisch im Krankenhaus machen,
indem wir eine Röntgen machen, indem wir Blut abnehmen,
indem wir gucken, ob die Tests der Influenza oder Covid positiv sind,
den wir nicht sprechen, kann man arbeiten.
Wenn der Patient jetzt zum Beispiel ein unauffälliges Röntgen hat
und er hat wenig Infektwerte, kleines CHP, oder niedriges CHP
und er hat ein Influenza-Test positiv,
dann müssten Sie ihm keine Antibiotikun geben.
Dann können Sie ihn antiviral therapieren, je nachdem,
wie schwer er krank ist.
Kommt immer drauf an.
Aber wenn er eine Lungenentzündung hat,
ist es wichtig, ihn schnell mit einem Antibiotikum zu behandeln.
Na, als sonst auch schlimmer werden kann.
Das ist immer wichtig.
Der Patient ist jung, er kann also ambulant behandelt werden.
Wenn der Patient jetzt 65 Jahre alt wäre,
eine bekannte COPD hätte oder weiß ich nicht,
sonst irgendwelche Kurmorbilitäten,
dann müssten Sie oder sollten Sie ihn am besten
stationär aufnehmen für eine intravenöse Therapie.
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe da sonst Fragen.
Herr Oberarzt, ich würde gerne wissen,
ob in Krankenhaus Sedimentation, das heißt BSG,
sehr, sehr bestimmt.
Zuletzt nicht bestimmt, ja?
Keine Vellivanz.
Okay.
Aber in Deutschland generell wird BSG sehr wenig bestimmt,
wenn Sie eine Verdachtung für eine rheumatische Erkrankung haben
oder eine Autorhauferkrankung, so etwas im Beispiel, dann.
Aber ansonsten BSG sehr selten.
Okay, CRP ist genug.
CRP oder Pukastuni.
Okay, Pukastuni.
Rheumatisch, Autorhauferkrankung und Malignanz.
Ich denke auch.
Oder was?
Malignanz.
Genau, wenn Sie Verdacht auf Malignanz-Krankung haben, ja.
Okay, danke.
Aber nicht im Routine-Labor.
Nicht, wenn Sie in der Ambulanz sind oder beim Haushalts,
wird das sehr selten gemacht, nur bei dringendem Verdacht.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Was haben Sie durchmüsst?
Das ist ein der Erleutern.
Im Praxis gibt es eine Leitlinie, CRP und Pukastuni.
Können Sie erntenen?
Also in der Regel normalerweise machen wir Pukastuni sehr selten.
Im Hausarzt, nur wenn wir einen dringenden Verdacht haben.
Bei uns ist es so, dass wir CRP kontrollieren.
Und wenn wir dennoch ein unklares CRP haben,
also dass nicht so hoch ist, zum Beispiel haben wir,
wir können nicht entscheiden, ob es viral oder bakteriell ist.
Und wir haben mal ein niedriges CRP von 3, 4, 5, 6.
Dann würden wir noch gegebenenfalls Pukastuni dazu machen,
um das zu kontrollieren.
Okay, danke schön.
Sonst noch Fragen, Kollegen?
Pukastuni macht man selten, weil es sehr teuer ist.
Ja.
Es kostet viel Geld.
Der Bakuai ist...
Darf ich letzte Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Herr Oberarzt,
diese Patient hat eine Flugticket für Reisen
und jetzt Sommerzeit, ja, zum Beispiel.
In Sommerzeit, das ist Kinderferien zum Beispiel,
darf er fliegen?
Gute Frage.
Ich musste fragen, während ansteckend oder so, ja.
Ja, gute Frage.
Also ein Patient mit einer lohen Entzündung
würde ich nicht empfehlen, zu fliegen.
Ja.
Ein Siebenteil später...
Aber wir können kein Verbot machen.
Wir können nicht sagen, sie dürfen nicht fliegen,
sondern das macht der Patient selber.
Wir dürfen nicht sagen, sie dürfen nicht raus oder so.
Er kann selber entscheiden, alles.
Warum empfehlen Sie nicht?
Er hat eine lohen Entzündung.
Eine lohen Entzündung ist potenziell sehr gefährlich.
Richtig?
Ich weiß nicht.
Warum gefährlich?
Haben Sie schon eine lohen Entzündung gehabt?
Ich habe nicht, aber zum Beispiel,
diese Patienten denken,
wie CRP ist zum Beispiel 20 Milligramm pro Desiliter.
Ja, gucken Sie, Sie müssen unterscheiden.
Sie müssen nicht das Labor therapieren.
Sie müssen den Patienten therapieren.
Es kommt zum Beispiel...
Sie dürfen nicht sagen 100, 200, 300 oder 10 oder 5.
Es kommt darauf an, wie schwer krank der Patient ist.
Beispiel, kann der Patient eine legionelle Pormonie haben?
Legionelle Pormonie haben nur ganz kleine CRP.
Labor ist unauffällig.
Wenig Leukozytin, wenig CRP, aber er hat eine Lubert Pormonie.
Zum Beispiel.
Das sollte er nicht fliegen, oder?
Es ist gefährlich.
Zum Beispiel, Sie dürfen nicht alles am Labor festmachen.
Die Kriege ist führend.
Richtig?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn Sie ein Labor haben, kann das heute CRP von 3 sein,
aber übermorgen 300 sein.
Richtig?
Ja, danke.
Wir verstehen aber dürfen und verboten nicht.
Wir dürfen nicht verbieten.
Nur empfehlen.
Nur empfehlen. Wir sind Berater.
Wir dürfen nicht sagen, wir dürfen auf keinen Fall fliegen.
Wir wissen nicht, was der Patient macht.
Können wir jetzt zweite Pfangen an?
Danke.
Können wir die
Wenn du keine Stärken oder Stärken nimmst, dann nimmst du keine Stärken, dann nimmst du keine Stärken.
Manche Stärken schreiben Stärken, Stärken schreiben Stärken, und die Hospitalis schreiben Stärken.
Aber für die Intl. nicht viel gemacht.
Die Covid-Bereihung wird nicht gemacht?
Ja, die Covid-Bereihung wird nicht gemacht.
Dann nimmst du diese Stärken, dann nimmst du diese Stärken, dann nimmst du diese Stärken, dann nimmst du diese Stärken.
Das ist ein
Wenn du nicht ein Felsingränzchen hast, dann schreib dir das direkt.
Ja, eigentlich.
Das ist ein Felsingränzchen, aber wenn wir das aufhören, dann machen wir es noch öfter.